I don't even want to be around my
sisters because it just gives me anxiety
the sister saga continues on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians Courtney still
feuding with Kim and Khloe there's two
new things in her life boyfriend and her
therapist ever since then she's been a
Raging [ __ ] and instead of her owning
it or whatever she takes it out on
everyone else the solution group therapy
where things got emotional everything is
the show is more important works more
important working is just it's not my
top priority it's never going to be but
by the end things sort of smoothed over
Gordy even admitted she wants to change
I'm evolving I don't want to be the
[ __ ] like not in touch with my
feelings person that I was before
definitely lots of change in Courtney's
life these days last week a source
confirmed to ET the 39 year old reality
star after 25 year old boyfriend Eunice
Benjamin called it quits after nearly
two years of dating but Courtney seemed
to be in good spirits when she hit the
town on Thursday to celebrate her sister
Kylie Jenner's 21st birthday alongside
her ex Scott Disick
you
[Music]